Hey! Welcome to a new season of Project Kamp, number 3!
We have many cool things planned for this year!
We already have the people here!
New projects coming up!
But, in this video, we're going to show you
some things we did this winter...
Some upgrades we made, some improvements, so...
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
So, this winter, it was actually super rainy...
Here is a graph from the internet, where you can see
the amount of rainfall, in the last 10 years.
So, there was really a spike this year...
And, we thought Season 1 had a lot of rain!
So, one big thing I learned this week,
is that it actually rains quite a lot around here...
But, actually, this year was even more...
But, to be fair, you do notice it a bit less now.
Because, we had a house,
where it was nice and warm, and dry.
And, we had a waterfall we could look at,
which was cool with all the rain.
But, it still does have a few downsides,
living in shipping containers, and in vans.
So, let me show you a few of those winter downsides.
So, winter in the van can be a bit rough...
But, not because of the cold,
but of the rain and humidity.
So, we needed some upgrades.
And, first, it's really nice to have some dry area outside.
So, you can leave your shoes outside,
without getting it full of rain.
And, second, it wears out the vans,
especially if they're under all this rain...
Mine was getting rusty, and some painful leaks we're appearing...
It's intense being outside all the time, so I wanted to make a big cover,
before the intense winter started.
Got some tubes, connectors, a big tarp...
Some rope...
And, anchors.
Time to set it up!
Let me also give you an update on the waterfall.
So, at the end of last season,
we repaired the water gate at the lagoon.
And, we got to test it, with the first rainfall.
But, during winter, it became an awesome landscape,
with more than 12 waterfalls altogether.
A lot of rain has fell!
So, I want to show you what
the waterfall looks like now, after a bit of rain.
A really fun place to be in winter, with all this energy flowing...
So, we continued to work a bit there...
Aiming to have a nice place,
where we can be in summer.
Cleaning the area around it up a bit more...
Cutting a big, old, burnt chestnut...
It burned to death from a recent fire.
Chopped it into smaller pieces,
so we can use it as firewood in the house...
Also, started cleaning up the terraces,
that were originally there, and planted some grass.
Hoping this would be a nice place to sit in summer.
Also, moved some of the big rocks around...
To improve the flow, and clear everything out of the water.
And, it's really nice to use these big amounts of water,
that are coming in to clear everything up.
And, also, repaired the small wooden gate,
that controls the water flow on the right top side.
It's pretty cool to use this water system, that was originally there,
and play with the different dams, and openings.
And, this is what it looks like now, in spring time, after winter.
The grass has already grown pretty well.
Seems like we could use this in summer, huh?
So, all this water flowing here, is the same water,
that flows in the creek on our land.
So, here are some updates from Julie,
to see how it's going down the stream.
So, here we are at the creek!
After a nice rainy winter, we have the creek flowing again!
So, by being so close to the creek,
we also make use of it, and plant some fruit trees.
Now, in spring time, there are some new leaves coming!
Okay, so, last year, we have been clearing quite a bit of the creek.
Unfortunately, we noticed that it was too big
of a job for one season...
So, we continue on this, this year.
You can see here it here: one big pile of old brambals from last year.
But, as you see close by, the new ones are already coming back...
Nature is taking over.
The creek was not the only thing we cleared, last year.
Let's have a look at the well!
So, last year, we placed a piece of the old shower,
on top of the well.
Just making sure that the animals don't fall into the well...
Or, a human...
As you might remember from last year,
we were scooping out the bottom layer of the well.
At the moment, there is quite a lot of water in the well!
This year, we're going to keep an eye on it,
and see how it reacts...
-A small fish?
No! It has four legs!
Maybe, it's a salamander?
- Nice!
Enough about the well now!
Let me close this up with the old shower...
And, let's give you a bit on the new shower!
So, here we are at the new shower!
We added a little door, so the privacy is even better.
To be not as exposed as we were before...
Let's have a look inside!
So, here we are, at the bottom of the shower.
Let's see how the basin is doing!
Wait, so, some extra information,
why we are having a look at the bottom.
This basin is part of a research we did last year.
Trying a new type of cement...
It's experimental, so I wanted to show you what it
looks like, after an intense winter, and some months of usage.
So...
No cracks!
It's all looking good!
A bit dirty, but it is what it is.
Water flows away easily, and no stops during winter
So, the shower has been behaving quite well!
The only thing that we see,
is that there is some mold appearing.
Have a closer look.
So, it's red cider with linseed oil,
but it's getting a bit moldy...
So, the wood is very interesting how it reacts during winter...
But, Adrian will tell you more about that!
Last year, as you might have noticed, we built three yoga decks,
in three different places of the land.
We used three different kind of wood,
to check what behaves better.
This is a yoga deck made out of eucalyptus.
A tree that you can find everywhere around!
It became very dark now...
It's in a shady place, very close to the swamp.
What happens with the eucalyptus sometimes,
is that it cracks, and moves a bit more than the other wood.
But, still behaving..
So, we're on the top platform!
This is made with pine wood,
and protected with linseed oil.
It's very exposed to the sun, to the wind, to the rain...
So, even in the same spot, you can find different results,
depending if it's exposed to the sun, or not.
If it dries or not...
And, if it doesn't dry, it gets mold...
If it dries, it loses the color...
So, here you can see it's way more moldy than in the top.
So, it's a little challenge to try to avoid the more chemical products.
Like, the varnishes, and these kind of things...
And, try to use only natural materials,
and natural products like linseed oil.
It's a matter of testing, balancing, and checking what's better.
We're in the bottom of the land, at the bottom deck now.
This is built with red cedar on the top.
It's protected with an artificial oil.
This used to be the product we used,
for the first structures we have made in Basekamp.
For the floor, it's very good protected, and it's using red cedar.
As you can see!
Even, if it's exposed to the sun,
to the rain, and it's close to the creek...
Which, makes the place a bit humid.
It's perfect in it's state, like the first day.
You can see that we treat the top with this product...
But, on the bottom, we let it grow.
The result of the red cedar is quite good!
It's a wood that is very suitable for being outside.
Because, even if it's raw: no mold, straight, no cracks...
It's a bit soft maybe, sometimes for some uses...
But, so far so good!
We are now in Basekamp.
Let me show you a funny fact!
So here, we have a funny roundabout.
Of course, the other way around...
Made out of red cedar, during Season 2.
Not a single protection, but all clean, and mold safe!
Funny to see! Let's see!
We are now in the Basekamp structures.
This is pizza hut we built, during Season 1.
We oiled it with linseed oil.
We re-oiled it at the end of Season 2 again,
but still, you can see it's full of mold...
it's getting a bit ugly with this color covering...
Black dots, some white parts...
We are still looking for a nice way, to protect our structures.
We still didn't find a way...
But, we keep on working on it!
Last thing, I wanted to show is our pizza oven.
So, from the beginning, it started to have some cracks...
We think that is, because of the expansion,
and the contraction of the metal door.
So, it creates this crack in the front.
But, with the time, it went a bit too crazy...
So, we are losing some parts...
At some point, we had some leaks in some parts of it too...
Under the oven, there's something that made us
quite worried at some point...
I feel that now it's still standing okay, but...
It start to heat up a bit too much,
at the bottom of the oven...
So, it got a bit burnt...
But, still working good!
Doesn't need to do much, besides putting wood,
keep the heat, and then we bake...
Pizzas are still tasty, and the bread is
getting tastier and tastier too!
So, yeah...
So far so good!
So, these were some updates of things,
that were happening in the winter...
But, there's also some stuff to prepare,
before the people are coming for the new season...
And, the first one, is to get our workspace up and running.
So, currently in the workspace, we're gonna tidy it up a bit.
But, also, re-stock...
Some things are missing, like this screwdriver.
Filling up the screw system, and making sure
all the paint is back in stock...
So, making sure it's ready, for new people to come!
Many different kinds of paint, and we need to get paint system...
It's a mess.
It's a bit messy, but slowly, we're getting there!
We need to repair some tools.
Also, some things are broken, like cables that got ripped.
Safety glasses: some are broken, some are a bit wore out...
This doesn't work -- no trust...
So, we also have a bunch of drills that got bland...
We don't want to use them again...
We could sharpen them by hand.
But, we know that it's a difficult process,
to sharpen them by hand, on the grinder...
So, if you have any solution, or any nice sharpener,
that we could install here potentially, just let us know.
Okay, so, next: we have a rougher situation,
that shows the real side of winter here.
- A lot of rain!
Please stop eating, and finish your drink, before we move on...
So, before winter came, we made sure everything was stored dry.
And, we thought that would be enough,
to keep things safe...
But, apparently not...
Not for Mr. Mold.
So, for instance: here you can see a cabinet,
under the roof, getting all moldy...
The handle of the pizza oven got all moldy...
Some wooden spoons in the kitchen...
And, especially textured surfaces, even more, like this glove...
It was pretty rough, seeing this happen over winter, with all our stuff...
And, the humidity also affected some of our metal structures...
They got rust on top, and we all just noticed that some mice
were walking around in the kitchen...
So, yeah, time for a deep spring cleaning
and repair upgrade job to the kitchen.
So, we just dismantle everything, and take everything
out
We really go into the very moldy corners,
and a lot of mice flew around...
We put everything out...
And, we clean it.
- Spring cleaning?
Spring cleaning...
So, we're currently repainting some of
our metal structures, that are in the kitchen.
Like the cabinet, and stuff,
because they got a bit rusty in the winter.
And, just after using them...
So, some maintenance...
Look at this brand new shelf!
Last season, we finished most of
the renovation of our small ruin.
The long-term goal is to use it as a guest house.
But, until it's ready, we use it for whatever is most needed.
So, it was awesome for winter, for example...
No mold here, just comfort and heat.
And, for the coming season, we want to use it as an office.
So, we have a proper space to work on the computers,
video editing, and so on...
- Make a short video
each week to keep the algorithm happy...
I mean, Basekamp is okay, but it can get annoying
to do computer stuff, with the heat, the rain, the flies...
- Damn flies...
And, the noise that happens all around...
And, we actually already have a big table!
You might have seen us taking it out of
the container in Season 1.
It was very heavy!
Made of an old bowling track.
And, we thought of putting that into the ruin,
which will become an office.
We also have with it: a big mess...
We have to take everything out!
So, that we can pull the bowling table,
and we can paint it back a bit...
And, use it for the office.
Now, it's all rusty...
So, now, the table is ready!
All painted, and all clear...
It's ready to go down, which will be a big task!
Because, not only is it super long, but it's also super heavy...
Which, means that we will have to take
the table all the way around the roads...
And then, the table is four meters.
It means that we have to do some funky angles,
in order to put it through that door, into the house.
Which, means that we have to take down a few of these mimosas...
It's kind of a pity, because they are quite of
a chunky tree, and giving a good shade.
But also, they are, according to regulations,
too close to the house, so it's also good to take them down.
So, this afternoon, Jan will be chopping down some mimosas.
So, that we can go to the next step, of bringing the table.
- I'm ready!
So, we assembled a big team, to move a big table.
It would be a funny task,
and we are not sure we will make it...
Make sure the wood is underneath, Julie,
when we put it down there.
- Pull this one!
Completely, yeah?
- Enough?
That the wooden top hits it...
- Okay...
Okay, good!
- It's gonna break!
The woods breaking!
- Which one?
This board, here?
- Now, we're in the air...
Okay, now, you need to pivot...
It fits!
- Pivot on here, but don't slide!
Adrian, the back comes to me.
We managed.
Kind of a hard task, but now we just need the easy parts...
Which, is just putting some storage space,
chairs, and turning this place into a proper office.
At this point, we are almost ready for the season to start,
and have the people come in.
This year, we are going to be with more,
at the same time in Project Kamp.
Last season, the maximum was 15.
This year, we will go up to 25,
but the peak will be around summer.
For now, we have the first new campers arriving!
They come from different parts of the world,
with different skills and backgrounds.
Many of them come with their vans.
Quite a coincidence that hey are all white...
And, some others will stay in tents.
For this, we still needed to brush cut the area,
and set up the tents itself.
But, with them around, it was a super fast action.
And, we could do it in a couple of hours!
Okay, one last thing we wanted to do was weeding the garden...
Last season, it was nice and tidy,
and was a source for nice herbs and teas.
But, over the winter, it got completely overgrown.
Weeds took over the place,
and many plants froze and died.
We kind of like the wild look,
but it can easily get out of control.
And weeds don't let other desired species grow.
Okay, so, we will now transform
this winter garden, into a spring garden.
So, we worked hard on it, because we wanted
to have it ready, before the people come.
But actually we didn't manage to finish it on time...
And anyway, now we are with more people,
it's a less challenging task, and we can do it super fast!
Yeah!!!
All right, so, that was it!
The Kamp is now ready!
The people are here...
Time to take on new projects!
In the next video, we're actually going to
show you all the things we're going to do in the next season.
If you already want to see that video,
make sure to support us on Patreon!
If not, we'll just see you again, next week!
Same time! Same channel!